it's no secret to many in our audience
that I don't like Papa John's Pizza and
I don't like Papa John John Schneider
Schnatter I don't even know how his last
name is pronounced he's the guy from
Papa John's Pizza he's got a lot of
money worth reportedly nearly a billion
dollars on the basis of selling very
very bad pizza
he's an uninformed ideological clown and
you might remember back during the
Obamacare debate John Schnatter opposed
it he said you know my pizzas would have
to get like 10 to 15 cents more
expensive unless I wanted to just like
lose 10 to 15 cents of profit if I were
to give everybody healthcare on the
basis of what Obamacare would dictate
and of course I said at the time wait
wait a second you're saying that if you
paid if you rather charge 15 cents more
on your pizzas everybody would get
health care that would make me more
likely to go and get pizza from Papa
John's that would be a really good thing
but he didn't like it that wasn't
something that he wanted then during the
NFL national anthem kneeling protests he
criticized the players who were kneeling
because what his sort of hypothesis was
that the was that the kneeling generated
bad press for the NFL and thus made it
so that his advertisements for papa
john's pizza in partnership with the NFL
weren't as effective at getting him
business which is a really great way to
excuse the fact that your pizza's
terrible John Schnatter has now resigned
after using a racial slur during a
conference call and Papa John's stock
price has been falling as a result and
this happened a couple months ago during
a conference call where Schneider said
the n-word in the context of I guess he
was complaining that other fast-food
founders had used the n-word and didn't
suffer consequences and I guess that
that was like upsetting to him or he
found it to be hypocritical or some kind
of double standard he also told a story
during this same conference call about
how back in Indiana where he grew up
people would sometimes drag black people
from trucks attached to ropes
until they died which is a really weird
story to tell during a corporate Pizza
conf
Skol it's even funnier that this all
happened during a media training
initiative and the company that had been
retained by Papa John's to do the media
training immediately quit and said yeah
we're not gonna be able to work with
this guy it's like an episode of Curb
Your Enthusiasm one thing after another
just going wrong yeah were these like
action items for him we're gonna talk
about media training then we're gonna
get to you know the cost of pizza dough
yeah and then the racial slurs will
follow from that full damage control is
now going on Papa John's saying which
Nader said was inappropriate but rest
assured the views of Schnatter don't
reflect the views of the organization
and I am genuinely curious does anybody
who listens to or watches the David
Pakman show go to Papa John's Pizza and
if you do I want to know why you go
there instead of a local pizza place my
understanding is that the price
difference between Papa John's Pizza and
local pizza is not that drastic and I
think that there are Papa John's in
Boston but I couldn't tell you we're
like Oh idea you don't know either
when you were at Domino's Pizza Pat yes
was there a rivalry between Domino's and
Papa John's oh yeah all the time was
there really yeah the two drivers cross
paths you do not want to see what happen
it was really bad it seems like the
pizza when I last tried it which was
years ago in Western Massachusetts when
I had some friends that would order it
seemed like it was marginally better
than Domino's at the time but I know
that since Domino's is kind of like
rebranded so I don't know at that point
where the how dare you say that David we
strived for me mediocrity at Domino's
and Papa John's does not even compare
I've told I've spoken to someone who
says their family knows John Schneider
down and what wherever it is that I
think he's based in like Kentucky or
something like that and that privately
oh this is allegedly John Schnatter
admits to how terrible the pizza is but
he still managed to become almost a
billionaire so yeah bad pizza I mean if
he is a billionaire or almost a
billionaire you'd have to imagine that
his taste buds have gone up with his net
worth yes and so he would no longer like
his own pizza yeah he wouldn't be caught
dead at a Papa John's place he is only
going to get artisanal vegan pizza at
this point no doubt about that all right
so anyway
you know I
take some pleasure in the fact that a
bad person has finally had somewhat of a
fall from grace but he still is going to
make a ton of money off of this thing
and he's going to be just fine so in the
end who really wins and loses here I
don't know the losers are the people
eating the pizza that's who I've really
feel bad for today's program was made
possible in part by Blink asam / pakman
I love bling cast it's the really
perfect app for anybody who likes
politics and learning and if you're
watching or listening to the David
Pakman show I'm sure you'll love
politics and learning and what blinka
says is take the best and most popular
non-fiction books they condense them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting and you can
learn about politics philosophy
psychology economics often we don't have
the time to actually read as many books
as we would like I know that I'm at my
limit for how much I can read and this
way you can absorb the most important
valuable information from books in just
15 minutes maybe on your way to work
maybe on your way to the gym maybe
cooking vegan recipes at home whatever
is your thing and our audience can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it and I think you will you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for just about five bucks a
month you can go to be li NK is t.com
slash PA k ma n to sign up